welcome to the program at least two
people were killed and a child injured
after an explosion on the bridge linking
Crimea in Russia residents in the area
reported pre-dawn explosions the Kirch
Bridge has now been closed to traffic
and local media is reporting a section
of the bridge is damaged and sagging the
bridge which spans the Kurt Strait was
closed in October last year after a
truck exploded collapsing part of that
bridge where Rock McBride joins us now
from Cleary in Ukraine and Rob do we
have any more details about the cause of
this incident on the Kirch Bridge
yeah this does appear now to be a major
attack on this Bridge originally Sergey
Axion off the head of the Russian
appointed Administration in Crimea was
merely saying that this was some sort of
emergency advising people to uh avoid
the bridge the Russians are now saying
that this was the result of an attack by
what they call the terrorist regime of
Ukraine uh indeed explosions were heard
and an image circulating on social media
appears to show a section a complete
section of the roadway missing uh from
the bridge this is both a road and rail
connection the Russians say that rail
Services have now resumed across the
bridge from the ukrainians we don't have
any official confirmation they are not
neither confirming nor denying that an
attack has taken place but we are seeing
reports in Ukrainian media claiming that
this was some sort of joint operation
between the Ukrainian Navy and special
forces and that possibly a seaborne
drone was so used in the attack this was
attacked last October it's still unclear
exactly what the cause of that attack
was whether it was some sort of truck
bomb or some sort of again a drone but
that did cause major damage to both the
rail connection and the road connection
um it was reopened but only completely
restored and rebuilt and reopened fully
in February of this year and Rob please
remind us of the Strategic significance
of this bridge of course it's hugely
important to Vladimir Putin himself
that's right it has both strategic and
symbolic importance it was completed in
2018 as a landmark project amid great
Fanfare by the Russians a personal
project of Vladimir Putin himself and it
really if you like cemented the Russian
occupation of the Crimean Peninsula and
is one of the few links that Russia has
with this peninsula there is of course
the now the land connection from Don
bass through mariupole and melitoppel
from the occupied territories that
Russia has seized but we know that that
is vulnerable now to long-range missile
attacks from Ukraine there is also Land
and Sea connections with Crimea from
Russian ports but again those are
vulnerable and I think this is a further
reminder just of the vulnerability of
the Crimean Peninsula with a lot of
speculation that eventually as Ukraine
has said it wants to retake Crimea and
lay Siege to the peninsula itself
a Rob of course this incident happens
while all eyes are on the renewal of the
deal to ensure the safe grain export
from Ukrainian ports
that's right this is a hugely important
grain deal which runs out at midnight uh
today Monday uh this is a deal that was
signed last summer when the effects of
the war started to disrupt the very
important grain supplies coming out of
Ukraine we saw food prices Spike by 30
their real fears of uh escalating hunger
in places and parts of Africa and so on
as a result of this deal this uh
guarantees the safe passage of grain
ships from Ukrainian ports across the
Black Sea it was agreed with the
Russians but the Russians have been
unhappy about this deal for a long while
they have they are meant to renew it
every four months they have renewed it
only for two months which runs out today
uh Monday uh so there's a lot of
speculation about whether it will be
renewed or not but then in any case a
lot of the farmers in this part of
Southern Ukraine have their own problems
as a result of the impact of this war